because people are calling out the human  rights violations in Qatar that they  mistreat their women that they mistreat  migrant workers and LGBT citizens there  And yet when westerners call it out  they're told the West is just as bad on  all of those issues and they have  Draconian laws against abortion so  really we have no right to call them out  and we're morally unclean and you know  Qatar is is on a Level Playing Field  with us well so this is the story we  pulled it up uh so people have the one  love bracelets and symbols and cutter  was like no you you can't wear those  things and people are all shocked and  surprised they're not allowed to do it  it's the craziest thing to me they can't  even drink at this yeah they banned  alcohol which which was more of a  controversy